- All right, y'all so we've
reached the end of the hour,
but don't worry, I have one last story.
I hope you enjoy.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
All week.
We're celebrating Rad Mamas
but Rad Mama doesn't mean perfect mom
coz that doesn't exist
and if you think you are one,
you're definitely not.
Coz no one's a perfect parent,
but motherhood is tough,
and these last two years
have been especially hard.
More and more moms struggle with anxiety,
and that can be difficult
to explain to kids,
and their big feelings to put into words.
So that's why I really
appreciate a new children's book.
Children's book rather
written by two mamas.
It's called "Sometimes Mommy is Anxious.
A little book about Big feelings."
We have the mamas who wrote it dialed in.
So everybody say hi to Marci
and Lindsay who watch
on NBC 10, Philadelphia.
(crowd cheering)
(clapping)
Hi ladies.
So Marci, I'm gonna start with you.
So this is such a great idea for a book.
So how did you come up with it?
- So I'm a mom of two and so is Lindsay.
And I really started
having trouble with anxiety
and mental health issues
after I had children
and Lindsay suffered her
whole life pretty much
since she was a teenager
and she's always been my go to
our husbands have been best
friends since they were five.
So we really leaned on each other.
And I went over her house one day
and our two little boys
who are only four months apart,
were playing a game
where they kept bringing us books to read.
And she was like, wouldn't
it be great if there was
a book out there for that
mental health that we
can describe, you know, to
the kids what's going on
and why mommy's feeling this way.
And we looked and we
couldn't find anything
and so we decided to write one(laughing).
- Here we are.
(laughing)
- I love that.
So Lindsay, what do you hope
children get out of the book
- So really we just wanted to help fight
the stigma that surrounds mental health.
So many children really just don't know
that it's okay when you're
not feeling your best.
We had our book and we wanted to describe
and show different races and body types
and cultures and just show
that anxiety doesn't discriminate
and that a lot of mother
and children could see
themselves in this book,
and we have had such a
great response thus far.
So many mothers and our friends.
- It's exciting
- It's so exciting.
- Yeah.
- It's a really cool idea.
So thank y'all for doing this.
(crowd clapping)
- Thank you.
- We just want our kids to know it's okay.
Not to be okay.
- Yeah.
It's so it's such a great message.
So everybody pick up a copy
of "Sometimes Mommy is Anxious" on Amazon.
Thank you so much, Marci.
Thank you so much, Lindsay.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(crowd clapping)
- [Lindsay] Oh, thank you Kelly.
- [Marci] Thank you
- Thank you for having Us.
- Absolutely.
And that's not all our season long partner
Pilot Pen makers of G2, the
go-to pen of "The Kelly Clarkson
Show" wanna honor
ultimate overachievers, just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for thousand dollars.
That's $500 each is each.
(Laughing)
(crowd cheering)
- [Lindsay] Thank you.
- So go have a good Time on us.